[ Applause ]
>> Catalina Gomez: We
want to welcome all of you
who are joining us via
livestream as well.
We're very happy to be
livestreaming the program.
I only have a couple of
housekeeping items for you.
Just if you could please turn
off or silence your cell phones
for the duration
of this program,
we would greatly appreciate it.
And we also wanted to
let you guys know that we
as a Hispanic division have a
mailing list right in front.
If any of you are
interested in finding out more
about our program and our
projects, please sign in,
sign our sign-in
sheet [inaudible].
We are very excited for this
anniversary, and it's my honor
to introduce the
principal deputy Librarian
of Congress, Mark Sweeney.
[ Applause ]
>> Mark Sweeney: Thank you
and everyone, welcome here
to the Library of Congress.
I'm delighted to welcome
you on behalf of Dr. Hayden,
Librarian of Congress, to this
year's America's award ceremony.
For 25 years, the consortium of
Latin American Studies programs,
Tulane University's Stone Center
for Latin American Studies,
and Vanderbilt University's
Center
for Latin American
Studies have collaborated
with the Hispanic division
here at the Library of Congress
to celebrate children's
and young adult books
that portray Latin
America, the Caribbean,
and Latinos in the
United States.
I'm aware that there are many
here that have been involved
in coordinating this event,
and I want to welcome
Denise Woltering-Vargas
and her colleagues here
today to the Library.
But I would also like
to take this opportunity
to extend a very special
thanks to Georgette Dorn.
Having worked at the Library
of Congress for 55 years
and having served as the
chief of the Hispanic division
with great distinction
since 1994,
Georgette is retiring
next month.
She began her career at the
Library of Congress in 1962,
moving to the Hispanic
division in 1969.
In her later role as chief,
she initiated the digitization
of the Handbook of
Latin American Studies
and the creation of the online
website and the digitization
of the Archive Hispanic
Literature on tape.
As well as making the
collections fairly available
online, Georgette also
influenced those using
or interested in
using these resources.
Additionally, through
her administration
of the Huntington
Society Gift Fund,
Georgette has awarded
internships to hundreds
of undergraduate and
graduate students to work
in the Hispanic division.
Many of those interns
are now members
of the current generation
of Latin American bibliographers
in the United States.
Georgette's vision and her
passion for literature,
scholarship, and programming
have left an indelible mark
on our institution and have
strengthened the myriad roles
that the role the Luca
[phonetic] Hispanic culture
plays in the Library's
collections,
outreach efforts
and programming.
Indeed, the tradition of hosting
this particular event here
at the Library materialized
in many ways,
thanks to Georgette's belief in
the value of the Americas award.
We wish her a wonderful
retirement, and we thank her
for her countless contributions
throughout her career.
Georgette.
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
I would like to close by
just congratulating all
of those involved in the
America's Award, the organizers,
the winners, past and
present, and congratulate you
on your 25th anniversary.
We hope all of you
here and those
of you watching online enjoy
this afternoon's program,
and I will pass it to the
esteemed Georgette Dorn.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Georgette Dorn: I'm very glad
that my last official
function is giving the,
is hosting the Americas award.
We began 35 years ago with
the University of Wisconsin
in Madison, I'm sorry,
in Milwaukee,
and of course now we're doing
it with Tulane and Vanderbilt.
So welcome this year's
awardees, and I'm very pleased
to welcome everybody here.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Denise Woltering-Vargas:
Good afternoon.
My name is Denis
Woltering-Vargas.
I'd like to say thanks,
thank you, to Catalina Gomez,
Mark Sweeney, Georgette
of course.
Good afternoon and welcome
to the 2018 Americas Award.
On behalf of the consortium of
Latin American Studies programs,
Vanderbilt University and Tulane
University, we welcome you
to the 25th ceremony
of these awards.
We are very excited to be here,
sharing the ceremony with you
across the country, streaming
with fans across the country,
with our class members.
It's a great addition this year
to be streaming and celebrating
and engaging with the award with
communities across the country.
Our co-sponsors of this year's
award are working with teachers
to develop curriculum that
correspond with books,
forming book clubs, creating
book trailers, and much more.
The awards are administered
by the consortium
of Latin American Studies
programs and coordinated
by both Tulane and Vanderbilt.
Generous support
is also provided
by Florida International
University, Stanford University,
the Ohio State University,
UNC Duke consortium
in Latin American and Caribbean
studies, the University
of Florida, the University
of New Mexico, the University
of Texas at Austin, University
of Utah, and the University
of Wisconsin Milwaukee.
A lot of really great
support from our centers
from across the country.
Our awards are given up to two
books each year and are selected
for their distinctive
literary quality,
cultural contextualization,
exceptional integration of text,
illustration and design and
potential for classroom use.
The goal of this award
is to link the Americas,
to reach beyond geographic
borders, focusing instead
on cultural heritages
within the hemisphere.
I'd like to take a moment to
say thank you to our committee.
Many of our committee members
are here with us today.
This year's Americas Award
review committee was comprised
of teachers, librarians,
faculty, and community activists
from Tennessee, Texas, Illinois,
North Carolina and Wisconsin.
This year Paula Mason was
our chair of the committee.
She is a librarian for the
Waukesha Public Library
in Wisconsin.
Just to give you an
idea of the process
that our committee goes through.
In the fall, books arrive,
throughout the year.
By January we have our list.
We set up Skype calls in the
spring and chat for hours
over weekends about
amazing books,
and they are spirited
conversations
about the diverse cultures of
Latin America and the Caribbean.
Coleen and I are extremely
grateful for the hard work
of the committee, and
the care that they put
into this year's award
winners, the honorable mentions,
and the commended titles.
I'd like to share some
messages about our founder
of the Americas Award, Julie.
The Americas Award began
as an idea 25 years ago
by my colleague, Julie.
She is the associate director
at the Center for Latin American
and Caribbean studies
at the University
of Wisconsin Milwaukee,
a member of class.
She started the award when no
other award recognizing Latin
America and Latino
culture in children's
and young adult literature
yet existed.
Her idea became one of the most
important projects of class.
It has enabled scholars of
Latin America to come together
and engage with children's
literature in many diverse ways.
It has become our passion and
our responsibility to educators
to read and share authentic
and engaging literature
for the K12 classroom.
I want to thank Julie
by presenting
to her a symbol she
once created years ago,
a weaving from Guatemala
that represents the weaving
of stories and voices
of the Americas.
I'd like to invite my
daughter, Valeca [phonetic],
to share our token of thanks.
>> Wow.
[ Applause ]
I got to see the whole thing.
Thanks.
>> I want to thank
you by presenting this
and say muchas gracias, Julie.
Come on up.
[ Applause ]
>> Julie Kline: Good afternoon.
Wow, 25 years [inaudible].
In his 1998 acceptance speech
for the circuit at the Library
of Congress for the
Americas Award.
Author Francisco
Jimenez said for most
of my school days I didn't find
in the literature
the experiences
that I had gone through,
so I decided
that it was very
important to promote
in any way possible ethnic
American literature and also
to contribute to that
body of literature.
And I thought that it
was important to do
that because the curriculum,
what we study in school,
reflects who we are as a people.
So if we do not see
ourselves as students,
if we do not see ourselves
reflected in the curriculum,
in the literature, in the
music, in the art that we study,
then we do not arrive
at a good understanding
of who we are personally
and who we are as a nation.
From the start, our goals for
the Americas Award were simple.
To highlight books that allow
children and young adults
to see themselves
in the literature,
to encourage U.S.
publication of such books,
to showcase the diversity of
Latin America, the Caribbean,
U.S. Latin Next, and other
diasporic Americas communities
in the hemisphere, and
to encourage young people
to read engaging
stories about lives
and cultures perhaps
different to them.
The Americas Award was inspired
by the Children's
Africana Book Award, CABA,
created by Africa Access
with the Outreach Council
of the African Studies
Association.
The book award concept seemed
a perfect project to propose
to the class teaching
and outreach committee.
I had some background that
made me really interested
in internationalism
in children's books,
and the committee at the
time was extremely receptive
to the idea.
And we did an event
through my center
in 1991 called Reading
Latin America,
both at Columbia Teachers
College and in Milwaukee,
which was, I sort of count
that as a starting point
because it gave us a sense of
what was out there at the time
in terms of this kind of
content in children's books.
The class committee helped
shape the award criteria,
and in doing so,
we decided to focus
on the multi-cultural
international dynamic,
including the Latin Next
experience in the U.S.
and including all the Americas,
not just Spanish-speaking
countries and communities.
We also determined the award
should be more than recognition
of winners but rather should
include an annotated annual
bibliography of commended titles
to be a guide for classroom use
and for Library collection
development.
As we refine the aware rationale
and criteria and discuss what
to include and where
to draw lines, if any,
I remember the comment
by Linda Hahn Miller,
who was a former
outreach coordinator
at the University of Florida.
Said Linda, the world is made
up of lumpers and splitters.
That is, people who think about
commonalities and connections
and those who think about
difference in separation.
I think for all of us shaping
the early Americas Award,
we aim to be lumpers
through and through.
So the award was further refined
over the years by the expertise,
thoughtfulness, and commitment
of the National Review
Committee members, all of you
and all of your predecessors.
And as it's matured, other
children's book awards,
such as the Pura Belpre and the
Tomas Rivera were established.
Each award makes a contribution,
and we've dovetailed with each,
I think, in a way that
broadly benefits the field
of children's literature.
In the case of the Americas,
both the Award's recognition
of the diversity of
Americas and the inclusion
of a criterion focused
specifically on potentials
of classroom use helps make
it's contributions unique.
So, I remember writing a letter
after the first competition
when Becky Guenther, masqueraded
by Lula de la Croix
[phonetic] run,
I think we had a whole six
books on the commended list,
and wrote a letter
to the committee,
I believe there was onion
skin paper involved.
It was back then, and it said
something about we'll look back
on this 20 years from now
and look at what we started.
Well, it's been 25 years.
And there's been over 400 titles
recognized since 1993 as winner,
honor, and commended books.
And the ongoing relationship
with the Library
of Congress has given
us a remarkable way
to truly celebrate the books,
authors, and illustrators.
Creatively coordinated since
2011 by Vanderbilt and Tulane,
the Americas Award is stronger
and more vibrant than ever,
and it's enhanced by the
innovative outreach programming,
by colleagues at Latin
American study centers
across the U.S. Diversity
in children's literature
has a long way to go,
but we can all appreciate the
Americas Award and in children's
and young adult literature
has made a 25-year
and counting contribution
to diversity.
In recognition of books of
distinctive literary quality,
cultural contextualization,
noteworthy integration of text,
illustration, and design, and
potential for classroom use.
[foreign language
spoken] Thank you.
[ Applause ]
I do want to go back
very briefly to,
back to Georgette Dorn.
The relationship of the Library
of Congress has been really
valuable for the Americas Award,
and it was you and I at
a meeting in New Orleans,
getting in a car after
a committee meeting,
going to lunch, and Georgette
said, we should have this
at the Library of Congress.
And I said, uh-huh,
that'd be really swell.
It was because of Georgette
and the commitment of Georgette
in the Hispanic division over
the years that we've been able
to give this kind of
weight, this kind of value
to the Americas Award, and
it's very much Georgette
and the Hispanic division.
So, thank you, Georgette,
very much.
[ Applause ]
I believe the Americas Award
has a present finally for you
after all these years.
>> Denise Woltering-Vargas:
Can you [inaudible].
>> Julie Kline: If anybody
has helped with the weaving
of stories, it's Georgette Dorn.
Thank you, Georgette.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
My little boy [inaudible].
[laughter] Thank you all.
[ Applause ]
>> Connie Sharp: My
name is Connie Sharp,
and I'm a district librarian
for Metro Public Schools
in Nashville, Tennessee.
I am honored to serve as
a review committee member,
and I'm thrilled to
be with you today.
I would like to recognize
the 2018 Americas Award
commended titles.
Several English-Spanish
bilingual picture books made our
commended list.
One such book is
The Little Doctor,
written by Dr. Juan Guerra,
and illustrated by
Victoria Castillo.
In this story, a young boy
dreams of becoming a doctor.
This delightful book is based
on the writer's childhood
experience,
and it is my pleasure to welcome
its author, Dr. Juan Guerra,
his wife, Tammy, and their
sons Salvador and Sebastian,
to our ceremony today.
We are pleased to welcome you--
[ Applause ]
We are pleased to welcome you
and are inspired by your story.
In Marti's Song for
Freedom by Emma Otheguy,
illustrated by Beatriz
Vidal, we learn of Jose Marti
and his tireless
efforts in speaking
out for Cuba's independence
from Spain as well
as the love he shared
for his two countries.
Another biographical
piece is Ruben Dario,
written by Georgina Laazaro
and illustrated by Lonnie Ruiz.
In this poetic piece,
readers learn the story
of Nicaraguan poet,
journalist, novelist,
and diplomat, Ruben Dario.
Little Skeleton's Countdown
to Midnight charmingly
captures the celebratory spirit
of día de los Muertos.
Author Susie Jaramillo
engages readers of all ages
in the countdown through rhyme
and enticing illustrations.
Young People's Poet Laureate
and former Americas
Award winning author,
Margarita Engle captivates
us with her poetry in Bravo,
poems about amazing Hispanics.
The vibrant illustrations
of Rafael Lopez complement
each diverse character
and the role they
played in history.
Margarita is recognized today
for having a second title
on our commended
list, Forest World.
In this timely novel written
in verse, she introduces us
to the story of two siblings,
one in the United States,
and one in Cuba, who
were unaware of the other
until they are reunited to
spend a summer together in Cuba.
Family stands as a
strong theme of several
of our commended titles.
In The Epic Fail of Arturo
Zamora, eighth grader,
Arturo's summer gets off
to a pretty typical start
until things go awry.
Author Pablo Cartaya
tells an intriguing story
that will have you rooting
for Arturo in his efforts
to save not only
the family business
but his community's
identity as well.
Keeping with the theme of
family, The Inexplicable Logic
of My Life, written by Benjamin
Alire Saenz, tells the story
of a white 17-year-old boy
raised by a gay Mexican father.
It is a story of resiliency,
what makes a family,
and the connections
that bind us.
In The First Rule of Punk,
author Celia Perez introduces us
to Maria Luisa, better
known as Malu.
After moving to Chicago from
California, Malu must deal
with the familiar changes
of being a new kid in town
and embracing her punk identity.
We see a young girl become the
hero of her own story in Lucia,
the Luchadora, by
Cynthia Leonor Garza,
illustrated by Alyssa Bermudez.
This delightful book
offers a cultural view
of Mexican superheroes
and celebrates the courage
and determination of
girls all over the world.
Previous Americas Award
winning author, Monica Brown,
brought us The Biography
of Frida Kahlo in her book,
Frida Kahlo and her Animalitos,
illustrated by John Parra.
This captivating
story is presented
from the unique perspective
of her beloved pet.
In the thriller Disappeared,
written by Francisco Stork,
two Mexican teenagers
are inadvertently drawn
into the world of drug
trafficking, kidnapping,
corruption, and violence.
Our last commended
title this year is Sing,
Don't Cry, by Angela Dominguez.
This story is inspired by the
Mexican ballad, Cielito Lindo,
which is a loving tribute
to her grandfather,
successful mariachi musician
Apolinar Navarrette Diaz.
Please give a round of applause
for the 2018 Americas
Award commended titles.
[ Applause ]
And now I have the pleasure
of chairing the 2018 Americas
Award honorable mention titles.
Our first book, All
the Way to Havana,
written by Margarita Engle,
and illustrated by Mike Curato,
is the delightful story
of a young boy travelling
to the big city of Havana, Cuba,
in his family's old
blue car, Cara Cara.
Along the way they experience
the sights and sounds
of the streets, the
beautiful cars putt-putting
and bumpety-bumping
along the way.
This engaging story
celebrates the spirit
of the young boy's
family as well as that
of the Cuban people they
greet along the way.
Margarita Engle's masterful
use of onomatopoeia coupled
with the brilliant illustrations
of Mike Curato make this
an engaging read aloud
for the young reader.
Our second book,
Lucky Broken Girl,
is based on the inspirational
story of author, Ruth Behar.
Having recently emigrated
to New York in the 1960's,
fifth grader, Ruthie Mizrahi
[phonetic], a Cuban Jewish girl,
feels that she is finally
starting to fit in.
School is going well,
and she has become known
as the neighborhood
hot-scotch queen.
Tragically, Ruthie is involved
in a horrific car accident
that nearly cost her her life.
She is so badly injured that
she is forced to lie in bed
in a body cast immobilized
for nearly a year.
This inspirational story allows
us to witness the struggles
and successes that ultimately
form the diverse friendships
that bring hope, healing, and
happiness back into her life.
Please join me in congratulating
the 2018 honorable mention
titles, their authors,
and illustrators.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Emily Chavez: Good afternoon.
I'm Emily Chavez, and I'm the
associate director in the Center
for Multicultural Affairs
at Duke University,
and I'm here also on behalf
of the UNC Duke Consortium
in Latin America and
Caribbean Studies.
It is my great pleasure to
present this 2018 Americas Award
to Duncan Tonatiuh for
his children's book Danza!
Amalia Hernández and El
Ballet Folklórico de México.
You may know that Mr.
Tonatiuh is a prolific author
and illustrator whose
work has been recognized
by the Americas Award
several times.
In addition to this
award we present today,
Mr. Tonatiuh was a 2015
Americas Award winner
for his book Separate
is Never Equal,
and he won honorable
mentions in 2014 and 2016,
in addition to having
multiple books
on our commended titles list.
Thus, I would like
to thank Mr. Tonatiuh
for his many contributions
to Latin American
children's literature.
Danza documents an important
part of Latin American
and performing arts history.
It is the story of Amalia
Hernandez' life work
to create a dance company that
brought to life the history
and the many indigenous
identities and cultures
of Mexico through
contemporary movement.
Hernandez' dance choreography in
many ways was about recognizing
and honoring Mexico's
history and in turn,
Mr. Tonatiuh does the
same in telling the story
of Amalia Hernandez' life
long devotion to her craft
and the impact it made
on Mexico and the world.
In his typical [inaudible]
inspired style
with creative textures
and rich colors,
Mr. Tonatiuh draws
readers into the pages.
This book is the first of
it's kind to tell the story
of Amalia Hernandez to
a children's audience,
and in this way makes more
accessible a Latin American
pioneer in the arts.
I imagine young Latina dancers
and any young dancer reading
this story with pleasure.
Empowered with the knowledge
of who came before
them, who paved the way.
I would like to now
present Duncan Tonatiuh
with the 2018 Americas
Award for children's
and young adult literature.
[ Applause ]
>> Duncan Tonatiuh: Thank
you and I'm very happy,
very grateful to be here.
I want to congratulate my fellow
authors/illustrators whose work
is also being celebrated,
recognized today.
I'm very thankful to
CLAS to the committee
for celebrating my work,
for choosing my work,
and all these other
wonderful books
that you're presenting today.
I think, you know, the Americas
Award does a wonderful job
in doing that and highlighting
and creating this list of books,
this body of work that
celebrates Latin America
and Latinos in the U.S.
I also really appreciate
and feel very grateful to CLAS
for their continual support,
that they've recognized
some of my work in the past,
and in the job they
do, creating resources
to use the books
in the classroom.
I think that's something
very special and wonderful
that the Americas Award does
creating different guides
in different ways of not
only recognizing the books
but to then making
them useful to teachers
and to people in the classroom.
I take the opportunity to
thank the people at Abrams,
who made this book possible,
and I feel very grateful
to the people there.
And, you know, it takes a
whole team to create a book,
and I've been making books with
Abrams now for almost ten years,
and it's been a wonderful
relationship, and I'm very happy
that they've supported my work
and helped it be successful,
and I especially want to thank
my editor, Howard Reeves,
who has always been
very thoughtful
and has made my work
better by his thoughtful
and careful editing but also
for being a friend and just kind
of looking after me and
supporting my vision
in the books that
I want to create.
I want to thank my family, you
know, my wife, for her love
and for her partnership,
for being a partner
in this adventure.
To my kids, who are just my, I
have a three-year-old daughter,
[inaudible], and a
one-year-old son, Maximo,
who just bring a lot
of joy and happiness,
and I thank them for that.
And I just want to tell
really briefly a little bit
of how this book came about,
give you a little bit of sort
of the story behind the book.
My wife, Patty, she's a dancer.
She's classically trained,
and she does modern
and contemporary dance.
And the last year she's been
aerial dance with the hoop
and the straps and the trapeze.
And I've done a few
illustrations inspired
by her dancing, and I
like dancing myself and I
like watching dance, so I've
made some images about that.
And so it's something that I'm
interested in, that I like.
My wife's mother was a dancer,
and her grandmother was
actually a dancer too,
and my wife's mother,
my mother-in-law,
she danced with Ballet
[foreign language] in the '70's
for a few years, and so that's--
and it just kind of came up
in conversation at some point,
and that gave me the
idea of making a book
about Amalia Hernandez.
So that's sort of on one hand.
On the other hand, another
reason for doing the book,
like I remember, I grew up
in Mexico, and I remember
when I was like seven
or eight years old,
dressing up like a charro
and dancing the [foreign
language spoken],
and it's a very common
experience,
a very popular experience,
you know, for a kid,
especially I think, you know,
to celebrate a special occasion
like Mother's Day or the end
of the school year, to dance,
to do, to perform
a folkloric dance.
And later on when
I was a teenager,
I came to the United States,
and I saw in the United States
folkloric dance was also very
popular and important,
especially for occasions
when different kinds of people
celebrate their culture,
celebrate their heritage.
In the case of Mexican
American people, you know,
on days like Cinco de Mayo
or [foreign language
spoken] it's a way to show
that you're proud of your
roots, to display your culture,
and so I wanted to
do a book about dance
and especially folkloric
dance, because I know that it's
such an important experience,
not only in the country
where it comes from,
in this case in Mexico,
but also in the U.S., you know.
And when I heard my
mother-in-law talking
about the folkloric ballet, it
just made sense to me to do it
about Amalia Hernandez, a woman
that really dedicated her life
to learning about the
traditional dances of Mexico
and to then being able to
adapt them to the theater
and being able to share
then in the world stage.
So, again, I just want to say
thank you, I'm very grateful.
I'm very happy.
I feel very fortunate for
all the support and for all
that the Americas Award does.
So thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Paula Mason: Carefully.
[laughter] Good afternoon.
My name is Paula Mason, and
I'm a reference librarian
at the Waukesha Public
Library in Wisconsin.
It's a great honor to
be here with you today.
I have the privilege
of introducing a truly
phenomenal author, Ibi Zoboi,
whose debut fiction title
American Streets moved our
hearts and spirit
immensely this year.
Through Ibi's confident
and powerful prose,
we have the chance
to meet Fabiola,
a young Haitian teenager
who finds herself painfully
separated from her mother
as they seek une belle
vie, a beautiful future,
in the United States with her
aunt and cousins in Detroit.
This story is so many things as
once, but to name just a few,
it's a tale of great bravery,
resilience of spirit and faith,
and a culture and a family which
helped carry us through times
of unimaginable loss and
rebuilding our future
when everything falls apart.
It also pierces through
our hearts and minds
with the timeliest of
themes, such as immigration,
family separation, and
the senseless tragedy
of the young lives lost.
However, at the crossroads
of American Street,
Ibi never leaves the
reader behind without hope.
Rather, she brings
us alongside Fabiola
and her ever-evolving
journey towards achieving her
own dreams.
Thank you so much for this
gift, Ibi, and it is an honor
to present you, to have
you here and present you
with an Americas Award.
[ Applause ]
>> Ibi Zoboi: Good
afternoon everyone.
Thank you so much.
This is such a huge
honor for me.
Thank you to the consortium for
Latin American Studies programs
and everyone involved in this
award and award ceremony.
I'd like to thank my publisher,
Harper Collins [inaudible]
imprint, and I'd also
like to thank my editors,
Alisandra Balzer [phonetic]
and Haley Lagwich [phonetic] of
Alloy [phonetic] Entertainment.
I'd like to thank my
family and all the programs,
the writing programs and the
workshops that got me here.
I've been writing for 15 years
and trying to get published.
American Street is my debut
novel, and I'm so happy
and thrilled and honored to
see how it's been honored
over the last two years,
the feedback from teachers,
librarians, and students, and
I'm just overjoyed at the fact
that readers, young readers, are
still discovering this story.
I will share a little bit about
why, how American Street came
to be, why this sort of story
is very important to me,
and most importantly, I'm really
grateful that I am honored
by an award that upholds
Latin American culture.
I am a Haitian immigrant,
and as you know,
Haiti is not a Spanish-speaking
country.
It is a Francophone Caribbean
nation, and based on that fact,
it kind of stands
out on it's own.
However, it is also a
Latin American country
which I just discovered I never
considered Haiti being part
of this larger conversation
of Spanish-speaking countries
or ever associating
it to anything Latin.
Our history was that
of revolution,
of French colonization and
African cultural retentions.
So only recently did I begin
to think about what it means
to be a Latin American
nation and what it means
to be an Afro-Latinx nation.
My recently published book is
called Pride, it's the Pride
and Prejudice remix, or
just a light retelling
of the literary classic,
and it features a
Haitian-Dominican character.
And as you may or may not know,
Haiti and Dominican
Republic have been at odds,
historical odds, cultural
odds, and you know,
there's a language
barrier as well.
And I was thrilled
that Elizabeth Acevedo,
who is a Dominican author,
the author of Poet X,
did the narration for Pride.
And in that process,
in that sort
of collaboration we realized
that we were healing both
of our respective countries.
So being honored for this
award that has the title Latin
in it is also just, it means
a lot to me, because Haiti
in itself can be very isolated
from the larger Caribbean
culture
and within the western
hemisphere itself,
being dubbed the poorest country
in the western hemisphere,
being one of the countries
that has the closest ties
to African culture, and part
of writing American Street was
about retaining the
culture that has been sort
of bastardized in
the western media.
In American Street, Fabiola
holds onto her Vaudou culture,
and it meant a lot to me to
make that authentic and real
and not make our traditions
and our culture a
caricature in this novel.
And when readers and
thought leaders, teachers,
and librarians recognize that,
to me that is sort of defiance
and a pushback against what the
mainstream has been feeding us
for the last few decades
about my home country.
So, I'm going to share
the author's note
from American Street,
because I've only written it.
I remember it being a tough
process between my editors and I
to figure out the how's and
why of this story so that
when readers turn to the
last page, whatever it is
that happens in that last
scene in American Street,
there's an author's
note for readers to kind
of unpack what has
happened and for readers
to understand my intentions.
One of the things that really
care about is being understood.
And I don't always have,
authors don't always have the
opportunity to state their
intentions in a book,
and sometimes we have a certain
sort of insecurity in terms
of did I get my meaning
across, did I get,
did readers understand
what I was trying to do,
and sometimes those validations
come from awards like this.
And it also comes from the
committees who plan those awards
and read other books and put
your work up against others
and others that are
really qualified
as well and see it's value.
So, again, I have
to say thank you.
I have to put this down.
So while I did not
come to this country
as a 16-year-old, Fabiola did.
I came to this country
as a four-year-old.
I moved, the first
neighborhood I moved
to in New York is a neighborhood
called Bushwick, Brooklyn,
and I'll explain a little
bit more about Bushwick
and what it means to come
from such a beautiful island,
I think all the Latin Americas
are like that, tropical, warm,
family, love, food, and to have
that American dream and to come
from what's considered a broken
nation by the western media,
and it is in many
ways, to a broken city,
which Detroit is still
coming back from,
and many of our cities are
like this as well, and the kind
of conflict that happens
in that sort of exchange.
So the first seeds of American
Street were planted in me
when I read a New York Times
article entitled Last Stop
on the L Train, Detroit.
The article was about the
far-reaching gentrification
of Brooklyn, New York, and it's
progression towards Detroit,
Michigan.
The real last stop on
the L train is Canarsie,
but Bushwick is the
last stop for whites
and affluent residents who won't
venture too deep into Brooklyn.
I was four years old when
my mother and I left Haiti,
and Bushwick was our
first home in America.
I didn't know it then, but
1980s Bushwick was described
as resembling a war zone.
While our house on Hancock
Street was fairly intact,
other blocks were lined
with burnt-out buildings
and open lots littered with
torn mattresses and old tires.
When I read the New York Times
article, I remember thinking,
how does present-day
Detroit compare
to the Bushwick I grew up in?
It seems like there were too
many parallels to ignore.
I could transpose my
own life as an immigrant
onto the timelines of Detroit.
I could write a book that
rides the train from Bushwick
to Detroit and tell the
story of a girl, like me,
who found her way
to the other side.
While writing American Street,
I pulled from my own memories
of living in between
cultures, the experiences I had
in high school and the
many tragic stories
about the violence and trauma
that girls have endured.
In Haiti, many girls
dream of freedom to live
without the constraints
of oppression.
Yet, more often than
not, these girls
and their families leave their
home countries only to move
to other broken and
disenfranchised communities.
I kept thinking about how these
girls negotiate their own values
and culture with the
need to survive and aim
for the American dream.
When Trayvon Martin was killed
in Florida in February of 2012,
he had been on the phone with
Rachel Jeantel, the daughter
of a Haitian immigrant.
During her testimony in
the George Zimmerman trial,
I recognized a little
bit of myself in Rachel
and in the many Haitian
teen girls I've worked
with over the years.
We fold our immigrant
selves into this veneer
of what we think is
African American girlhood.
The result is more
jagged than smooth.
This tension between
our inherited identity
and our newly adopted selves
filters into our relationships
with other girls, with the boys
we love, and how we interact
with the broken [inaudible]
around us.
I saw Fabiola in these girls,
and that's how the
story was truly born.
I wanted to give Fabiola a
strong cultural connection
to Haiti so that she's
spiritually grounded when faced
with a tough decision.
While Vaudou is practiced by
many in the Haitian diaspora,
it still has a negative
stereotype in the media
as being associated with
evil and witchcraft.
Vaudou has a complex pantheon
and mythological system much
like Greek and Roman mythology.
Through Fabiola's eyes, her
new world and the people
who inhabit it are just
as complex and magical
as her beloved saint
[inaudible].
She infused Vaudou into
everything that happens to her.
This is the source of courage,
and I think she is more
American because of it.
This merging of traditions,
this blending of cultures
from one broken place
to another.
I remember those rides on the L
train with my mother very well.
Graffiti covered every
inch of the train cars.
I once saw a young man steel
a diamond ring right off a
woman's finger.
My mother pulled me in close
and prayed under her breath.
We'd made it to the other
side, just like Fabiola,
but what was this life?
I don't know what my life would
have been like if I had grown
up in Haiti, but I
know this much is true.
I would not have
told this story.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Colleen McCoy:
Thank you, Ibi.
Hi everyone.
My name is Colleen McCoy,
and I am the co-coordinator
of the Americas Award.
Thank you, again, to the Library
of Congress, to Georgette Dorn,
Catalina Gomez, and the Hispanic
division, to the founder
of the Americas Award,
Julie Kline,
and to all of the authors,
illustrators, and publishers
who submitted to
this year's award.
Thank you to the Consortium of
Latin American Studies programs
and all of these
years' sponsors.
And thank you to an
incredible review committee,
especially the committee
chair, Paula Mason.
The thoughtfulness and the
dedication of the award
of each committee member
is truly inspiring.
The Americas Award is not
just a children's book award
but also represents a
variety of resources
for teachers and librarians.
To commemorate this
special 25th anniversary,
we have put together a
comprehensive toolkit
for teachers, librarians, and
outreach professionals to use
as a guide for engaging with
books recognized by the award.
This toolkit provides classroom
activities, curriculum,
ideas for community events
and teacher workshops,
and many other resources
and will soon be available
on the class website
shown in your program.
We extend our gratitude
to Keira Philipp-Schnurer
from the University
of New Mexico
for leading this special
project and for her work
on our 25th anniversary
commemorative poster.
This special poster
features beautiful artwork
by Americas Award winner
Rafael Lopez, and we invite you
to take one with you today.
At this time, please join us
for a reception and book signing
with this year's winners.
You're welcome to purchase
titles just through these doors
to the back, and Ibi and Duncan
will be in the adjacent room.
Thank you all so
much for coming,
and we'll see you next year.
[ Applause ]